lo podrá hacer lo podrá hacer las veces
que sea necesarias de hecho él repetidas
repetidas veces ha dicho que se seguirá
presentando esto porque pues además
tiene precisamente el apoyo del
expresidente Donald Trump con quien
habló anoche y quien le dio la
espaldarazo a Kevin le dijo a los
republicanos a estos 19 republicanos
disidentes que por favor ya votaran por
Kevin mccarthy para elegirlo como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes para llegar a estos 218
votos necesarios y dejar de seguir
agrandando
esta falta de Unión por parte de los
republicanos a el propio partido no
solamente en cuanto a su agenda política
la agenda política republicana en el
congreso sino el partido en general y a
las aspiraciones que tendría el partido
en próximas elecciones además pues se
sigue se siguen proponiendo nombres
diferentes afroamericano
llegó a la cámara de representantes en
el 2021 republicano afroamericano que
también sería pues una opción según
varios pero que pues no se ponen de
acuerdo y
todavía no pasa el umbral de ni siquiera
los 205 votos se queda en los 200 votos
y esto pues obviamente no le permite
llegar a la mayoría Cristóbal estamos
viendo entonces Esta división al
interior de los republicanos Qué es lo
que está generando Esta división y que
piden para poder negociar para poder
tener consensos ya Incluso el
expresidente Trump les pidió que se
unieran y unieran fuerzas y votaran por
mccarthy cosa que no resultó como él
esperaba
concretamente lo que piden es que si
mccarthy es electo presidente de la
cámara de representantes cualquier
congresista republicano solo uno
bastaría con uno para que se reconsidere
la presidencia en caso de que él sea ya
confirmado En el cargo en los próximos
dos años lo que están pidiendo estos
republicanos es que bastaría con que un
congresista le pida una votación para
sacarlo del cargo y lo que está diciendo
es que pues esto no se sostiene porque
le quitaría además mucho poder a él de
avanzar la agenda política de los
republicanos y pues caería de alguna
manera preso en los Caprichos de
cualquier republicano de Lala radical
que simplemente quiera acabar con el
mandato de Kevin mccarthy eventualmente
si es confirmado o si no es confirmado
pero lo que otros congresistas están
pidiéndole y le están diciendo
directamente a Donald que si
definitivamente
votos Pues que simplemente haga un paso
al costado y pues pueda puedan elegir y
puedan pensar en otro candidato que una
al partido y que logre esta mayoría para
pues poder avanzar y poder empezar de
hecho con un paso básico que es
confirmar el resto de de congresistas
que se tuvieron que haber confirmado el
3 de enero Cristóbal rápidamente ya este
es el segundo día de votaciones Qué
consecuencias trae este bloqueo temporal
digámoslo así para la cámara de
representantes
consecuencias gravísimas y consecuencias
no solamente para el partido republicano
sino para Donald Trump quien a pesar de
haber dado el espaldarazo pues queda
abiertamente ya público el hecho de que
hay una división grandísima en el
partido que no lo apoyan a pesar de que
este insista en que respalden a Kevin
mccarthy y pues en las consecuencia es
que no se puede hacer absolutamente nada
en la cámara de representantes hasta que
no hay un presidente electo es decir si
no hay los republicanos no eligen pronto
presidente electo pues no van a poder ni
siquiera confirmar a los congresistas
que eligieron y avanzar en la agenda
política que ellos quieren sobre todo en
temas de económicos